Artificial Intelligence Program Developed from Needs
Cold War White and Mikio are bad at Megalonya and want to prove by writing it to
their advantage that their own gear is better than anything else
.  I wonder
why I didn't go
up to Jorring?
Well, if I drag him out again,
I'll leave him in Ging.
You guys already know, right? The sensor senses the opponent's geary movements and responds perfectly with automatic control.
It's the gear that senses it. The
opponent's gear's faint electromagnetic wave sensor is
quite frozen ground
.  I didn't want to fight, I
didn't even think about it, but I can do it with this
Uncle said that tonight's ceremony will be the centerpiece
Teppei can do it